これっしょ？
カメラマン）これっすね
いやぁ～～
あそことか、やばいよ、高さが
ほら、ほら、ぐねぐねぐねぐね！
意識やばいんでしょ？
カメラマン）徹夜で...
徹夜でこんなトコ来る！？
&%'￥'$%/@：＃（？）
夏と言えば、そう
とゆう訳で、こちらはですね、今...
静岡の、ある遊園地に来てるんですけども
こちらのジェットコースター。
どうでしょう
結構...
ガチモンだね。
自分で言うのも何なんですけども、
ジェットコースターが、嫌いです。
いつ、壊れるかわかんないし...
乗らなくていいじゃん（笑）
で、僕は思ったんですよ。
ジェットコースターに乗ってると、
気分悪くなる人いるじゃん
うーわ、やば
オ”エ”ッ　みたいな。
僕も嫌いなんですけども、
さすがに、そこまで行った事はない
いくらなんでも、気持ち悪くなったり
なんかこう...
吐き気を催すってのは、
ちょっと盛り過ぎだと思ったわけですよ、私はね。
盛り過ぎだと思ったわけなんで、
ジェットコースターに乗って
体調が悪くなるって、さすが無いと思ってるんで...
今回、僕がちょっと、ジェットコースター嫌いなんですけども、
体を張って、果たして、
ジェットコースターに何回連続で乗ったら、
体調が悪くなるのかを、
検証していきたいと思います。
マジでもう、体調が悪くなるまで僕は乗り続けます
カメラの人：って、誰もいないｗｗｗ
あれっ？どこ？どこだっけ？
あ、これか～
一回目かぁ
では、一回目。
乗っていきます！
アナウンス：では、お待たせしました。
アナウンス：それでは、スタートします。
アナウンス：手元の、安全バーをしっかりとお持ちください。
カメラの人：どうですか？
いや、まだ全然大丈夫
二回目行こう、二回目。
いや、でもやっぱ徐々に慣れていければいいと思うんで、
最初だけだと思うんだよ、キツいのは。
では、二回目行ってきます！
カメラの人：いってらっしゃーい
次行こう、次行こう、次行こう
ちょっと慣れました！
ちょっと重力的なダメージを負いつつ、
けど、慣れてきたから
もうちょい頑張ってみよう！
まだまだ、まだ行ける、まだ行ける
次は、最前列で
三回目クリア！
ちょっとやばいね...
いや、行けるよ
でもやっぱ、最前列よりは
ダメージの差は無い
四回目ですね。
もう、結構慣れてはきたんで
後はいかに自分のペースで、出来るかが
ポイントになってきます
行きましょう
五回目行ってきます！
じゃあ六回目行ってきます！
七回目クリアです。次行きましょう
何回目だっけ？
十一回目です！
行ってきます！